the blade of calling refers to melaner
as the one who walks alongside flame but
what happens if she sits alongside flame
what happens if you kill her at the very
beginning of the game with Fire's deadly
sin and the blood flame glitch this is
possible now don't worry she doesn't
stay dead and it doesn't ruin your game
but it does get us a really close look
at what is a very unique death animation
with her dying breath Melina casts one
last incantation a golden urge tree
erupts and remains here for a while
healing you in an AOE from all of the
burn damage that you just took giving
you back some health over time melaner
can also cast this unique incantation if
you summon her for the fight with morgot
and while it's rare she can cast this
spell during the fight as well not just
when she dies gameplay and lore wise
this is very similar to the spell
blessing of the earth tree which also
heals you with the tree's warmth and
Grace over time and melaner who was born
at the foot of the old tree certainly
has a really good claim to this powerful
manifestation of its power even if she
does feel compelled eventually to burn
it all away
in my last video about Michelob we
talked a lot about his unalloid gold
needles which can be used to repel the
influence of outer gods of course you
can give a needle to Millicent who
inserts it into her body to fight off
the Scarlet rot of the rot God but you
can also use the final version of this
needle to repel the influence of the
outer God of frenzy and remove the
frenzy from your eyes but what you might
not have known is that the original item
descriptions for this needle originally
said that to repel the interference of
the outer God you should Pierce this
needle into your eyes I wonder if they
changed this detail so they wouldn't
have to create a specific animation for
it can you imagine number three did you
know that the winged design of the
mausoleum Knights is clearly inspired by
the armor of the winged hussars who were
the Polish Cavalry between the years
1503 and 1702 use a faithlessness lucky
55 shared this side-by-side compare
Harrison of the two on Reddit and I love
seeing just how similar the armor design
is because it's such a grand excuse to
talk about why Elden ring and Poland as
well decided on such extravagant designs
so in Elden ring the winged
ornamentation of the mausoleum Knights
is intended to evoke the death bird and
so this feathered part of their armor
acts as and I quote a self-inflicted
curse that ties their spirits to the
land and this is also that they might
better serve their masters in death and
as for the Polish Cavalry the rear wings
were intended to Simply demoralize
enemies during their charge as the
hussars were the elite of Polish Cavalry
and I assume they were not a force that
you would want to see charging your way
the Polish assembled These Wings from
the feathers of raptors raptors are a
bird of prey who appear to exist in
Elden ring as well as these are the
birds that provided their feathers for
the Raven Mountain assassins in Elden
ring who also evoke the death bird and
actually have a chest piece called the
Raptors black feathers which states that
it is a ritual Implement for
transforming into a death bird if only
by imitation
number four is something I decided not
to mention in my video on Elden Ring's
Cosmic Sorcerers and it's that Radigan
shares a very compelling connection with
Raya lucaria's Knights of the cuckoo who
are the characters that bear this
twinned cuckoo bird as their coat of
arms so a cuckoo is a bird that lays
eggs in foreign nests so that other
birds can raise its children Instead
This I discovered is something called
brood parasitism which is kind of messed
up when you think about it cuckoo birds
even go so far as to push eggs and other
baby birds out of the foreign Nest so
that there's less competition for their
own offspring and Radigan kind of
exhibits this cuckoo Behavior with
ranala he doesn't go so far as to push
other children out of the nest but you
could argue that he does use Ronaldo to
birth three demigod children only to
eventually leave her with a Parting Gift
of a giant golden egg which ranala would
then treasure seemingly at the neglect
of all else the egg is just such a
curious symbol for this reason and you
could take this Theory further and argue
that radagan America might have helped
to establish the Knights of the cuckoo
they were after all a part of the
academy for a very long time and the
Knights of the cuckoo were established
on behalf of the academy for one the
crest of the cuckoo Knights is the
twinned cuckoo which you could argue
represents the twin body of Radigan and
America second the Cuckoo's circuit item
description even says that the cuckoo
knows the insignificance of physical
bodies now there is counter evidence to
this Theory and it's that the cuckoo
seems to date back to noxtila as there
is a legendary Black Moon of nextela
Talisman that features that signature
twin cuckoo design so you kind of have
to decide did Radigan America simply
co-opt this ancient cuckoo icon for
their own purposes or is the cuckoo just
his own thing and is coincidentally
similar to the whole situation with
Radigan and Ronaldo's Golden Egg
whatever the case you have to admit that
it is a pretty compelling Theory and it
offers a very welcome bit of
characterization for Radigan this hero
who only really appeared during the war
with Leonia and I think you could argue
that it was almost radigan's sole
purpose to get close to Ronaldo and undo
her from within and another law topic
that I just keep talking about are the
crucified folk that are found all
throughout limb grave many of these were
the guilty Hood item which has a
description that reveals that it's the
Garb of those accused of lesser crimes
indicated by the collar of sharpened
branches but back in version 1.0 of the
game the description read that it was
the Garb of spurned tarnish who were
forced into slavery in the lands between
it goes on to say that the tarnished
have been wandering into the lands
between from Beyond the Sea of fog in
dribs and drabs since times of old most
are killed on arrival but the few
unlucky survivors are taken as slaves I
wonder why this was changed the 1.0
description seems so much better for
number six there are some interesting
details on the Urge tree Sentinels as
well if you look close enough at them
you'll notice that they're actually
chained to their horses use a groom Grim
on Reddit pointed out that if you look
at their waist you can see how an ornate
chain wraps from around the Sentinel
down and then around the horse which I
think helps to explain from a gameplay
point of view anyway why they can't be
dismounted like other large enemies can
be on Horseback like the knights Cavalry
the oak tree Sentinels on the other hand
are unable to be separated from each
other for a very good reason so one
aspect of Elden ring that isn't talked
about very much is The Game's hardness
stat this dictates whether or not a
weapon will bounce off of an enemy when
the weapon is wielded with one hand
fextra life has a very helpful list
explaining all of these tiers if you
want to learn more but what I really
want to talk about is that did you know
that there's one enemy in the game that
absolutely no weapon can match in terms
of hardness all hail the crystal crab of
raihalukaria not even the coded sword
the cipherparter or whips are a match
for hardness of its shell another lesser
known mechanic is called Overkill and
it's something that you can use to
massively boost the amount of runes that
you receive in game so this has actually
been around in the soul series for quite
a while but basically if your first hit
on an enemy does damage that exceeds 150
percent of their maximum HP then you
will receive 20 more runes as a result
this is a nice perk for strength builds
or maybe magic builds that do a ton of
damage in one hit but in general I think
this mechanic exists because it kind of
helps the game scale rewards to the
strength of your character a little bit
as you continue to level up and get
stronger but with this Overkill mechanic
really comes in handy is when you're
engaging in Rune farming so 20 more
runes is a lot when it comes to
something like farming the albinorex at
moguin Palace so if you're currently not
making use of this you should consider
ways to make your character just that
little bit more powerful so that you can
hit that threshold where you deal more
than 150 damage in one go for number
nine everyone knows about The dactus
Medallion at this point and how having
two halves of it allows for easier
access to the Altus Plateau but did you
know that's not all that it does if you
have this in your inventory it also
prevents the two Guardian Golems at the
top from attacking you
for number 10 have you ever wondered why
certain enemies drop Bell bearings like
what even is a bell bearing right so
it's a term that as far as I can tell
doesn't actually exist in the real world
when I first read it though I thought it
said ball bearing and I thought it was
referring to those little steel balls
that go inside of an enclosure to serve
a purpose like rolling to reduce
friction or to roll inside of a pen and
apply ink so if I had to guess a bell
bearing might also be the little ball
that goes inside of a ball Bell
enclosure so that it might function as
The Clapper part of a bell which is the
part that gives the Bell its ring this
would make sense as we do give these
Bell bearings to the twin Maiden husks
who are finger maidens that hold the
staffs that if you look closely are
actually full of such ball Bells but why
do we do this why do we give the these
maidens these Bell bearings well bells
in the Elden ring Universe are a tool
that can be used to summon or call to
Spirits the best example of this is the
spirit calling Bell that the player uses
but this mechanic exists in other from
software games as well like the bell
ringing woman in bloodborne who also
Rings her Bell for spirits to fight on
her behalf so when the Twin Maiden husks
receive an NPC's Bell bearing we
speculate that this enables us to
interact with their spirit and learn
additional spells from them or receive
their items as if they were still alive
after all many bell bearings seem to
kind of hold the essence of perished
NPCs they might have even been born or
held by these NPCs as many bell bearings
appear to have like a fingerprint design
upon them so after really thinking about
this for this video I realized that the
word Bell bearing is quite an
impressively loaded phrase for these
little items it suggests that it's part
of a bell it suggests that it's been
born by an NPC or held and it tells us
that it provides a bearing pointing one
towards their spirit with a signature
chime perhaps so really props to the
translation or the writing team for this
one I always find it beautiful when they
use this kind of wordplay to describe
things so number 11 recently Twitter
user Diddy Colo shared this video and it
seems like the statue in the Shaded
Castle watches you whenever you have
your back turned only to turn away when
you get closer it's extremely creepy
until you figure out what's actually
going on here so after going to
investigate I realized that this was
actually being caused by a textures or
assets being loaded in depending on how
close your character is to them when
getting closer it's simply loading the
assets that make it look like the statue
is looking towards you that's not to say
this isn't creepy as hell I remember
something similar actually happened to
me with the inanimate doll in the
Hunter's Workshop in bloodborne I
entered the room and I swear the doll's
face moved and looked towards me and it
scared the absolute hell out of me but
now I finally understand why that might
have happened one thing I've always
wondered about is the sequence of events
that leads to you ending up in the
stranded graveyard at the beginning of
the game remember when you were defeated
by the grafted Scion and you heard this
laughs
foreign
it's as if you're dragged then thrown
through the air only to be submerged
underwater then you hear nothing until
you finally awaken in the stranded
graveyard now what I always assumed that
these sounds meant were that the grafted
cyan drags you after it defeats you then
throws you off the cliff into the ocean
below then eventually I thought that
your body might wash up towards this
beach here at a sort of high tide as
this beach does have a cave that leads
straight into the stranded graveyard and
I figured that it was here that Melina
eventually finds your body but another
theory was recently proposed by Shield
scuff in a YouTube short that reveals
that the stranded graveyard is actually
right below this crevasse in Lim grave
now falling into this crevasse usually
kills you but if you fly the camera down
there you do arrive pretty much directly
where your character awakens in the
stranded graveyard so as the theory goes
our character or at least the coffins
that are placed nearby these might have
been hurled down here in years past into
that crevasse there is also a bunch of
crucified bodies near the hole which
does kind of lend Credence to the idea
that this was a place that was used to
dispose of tarnished or criminals the
counter argument here however is that
there isn't actually a hole in the roof
of the stranded graveyard that aligns
with this crevasse I mean there is a
tiny hole but I feel like that's not
very convincing unless you argue that
there was like a landslide and it
covered it up there are a few caves like
this in Olden ring with clear holes in
the ceiling that don't line up with the
outer geography and I feel like that is
a huge missed Opportunity by from
software I think it would be really cool
if you could fall into a hole and then
end up in the middle of a dungeon and
have to find your way out so there's a
free idea for number 13 for a long time
amongst the high-level PVP Community
people were noticing instances where
they would block an attack and perfectly
Poise through it as well without taking
any knockback now in PvP and PVE this
sort of technique this sort of perfect
blocking technique could be extremely
useful because it enables the player to
take no damage and not take any movement
penalty either and just Poise through an
attack in order to deliver a punish or
even a backstab the only problem was
that it wasn't known how to replicate
this seemingly random event or at least
it wasn't until now thanks to a
discovery by Discord user CMG and thanks
to videos showcasing it by stilovsky and
gene9 we now know that to replicate this
quote-unquote irregular Poise event what
you have to do is be sprinting and then
take your finger off the sprint button
and put it onto the block button in the
exact frame where you would usually take
damage this performs a perfect block
with poise and it allows you to deliver
a punishing blow I've always craved some
sort of secular style Parry system in
Olden ring so I was really excited to
learn about this it's difficult to
perform for sure but it really does
heighten the skill ceiling of the game
and that's usually a good thing it hard
being a game developer and learning
about things like this though do you
remove the unintended effect or do you
Embrace when your game has the random
emergence of complexities like these I
tend to prefer the latter I still really
wish that Elden ring had some sort of
Chain Casting mechanic that was actually
baked into the game instead of being a
bug and speaking of the developers I
think we should give the animators in
particular some credit like yes when the
game first came out a lot of people
criticized them for reusing a lot of the
animations that existed in previous
games but
let's be honest that's not really being
lazy that's just being more efficient
because these animators are not lazy
they clearly put a ton of effort into
animating so many other things instead
for example have you considered that
almost every single enemy has a specific
animation for falling and remaining
asleep I know this isn't really a secret
but I feel like it still Bears
mentioning every animal so many enemies
and so many bosses all of them have
sleep effects designed specifically for
them even if it's extremely unlikely
that any player would ever inflict sleep
upon them and I bring this up as well
because in the recent Michela lore video
we talked about how they used to be a
mechanic where enemies could be found
sleeping out in the world and it was
required for a questline to harvest that
dream Mist there's a big part of me that
wishes that this mechanic or this quest
line would be patched into the game
maybe for Saint Trina they'll see or at
least it would be cool to see animals or
enemies just randomly falling asleep out
in the world so that all of these
animations could be put to use
speaking of sleep have you ever looked
up during your fight with ranala to see
where the scholars are respawning from
turns out they're all falling out of
these hanging cribs we've talked before
in another Secrets video about how these
beings are being rebirthed through
Ronaldo's great Rune of The Unborn and
the scholars themselves have dialogue
that talk about how they're being reborn
within ranala's Umbra or the shadow of
her Moon so to speak
before I go I'd like to quickly talk
about displate who have just introduced
a set of official Elden ring designs so
having a nice setup Space is really
important to me and hanging a set of
disc plates on your wall can really help
to add personality to a room displays
are printed on metal and the color and
texture they achieve is really
impressive and these official Elden ring
designs just look fantastic honestly I
love the shot of Godfrey and vike in
particular if you recall these artworks
were first shown off back when Eldon
ring was first announced and they always
give me this real Nostalgia kick for
that time whenever I say them but there
are way more official designs over on
their website so please if you're
interested use the link in the
description to purchase these as that
really does help me out and please let
me know which ones you pick up
anyway thank you very much for watching